moving on
our main story tonight concerns history
a subject so fascinating we're sometimes
willing to do crazy experiments like
this
scientists were able to mimic nessie
moon's voice
by recreating his mouth and vocal cords
with a 3d printer
it allowed them to produce a single
sound
excellent finally an answer to the
question that scholars have asked for
ages
what would an ancient egyptian sound
like if he orgasms while taking
antidepressants
but look sadly history isn't always fun
weird mummy ventriloquy it can be
painful too as america
has recently been reminded because
george floyd's murder has forced a hard
national conversation about this
country's presence which is
impossible to do effectively without
re-examining its past and unfortunately
that's not a conversation that all
americans are well equipped to have
because there are some embarrassing gaps
in many people's knowledge of us history
just look what happened a few weeks back
when the president in the midst of
nationwide black lives matter protests
announced plans to hold a rally in tulsa
on june 19th a decision
astonishingly tone deaf for two key
reasons
next friday june 19th is juneteenth an
annual holiday commemorating the end of
slavery in the u.s
as for tulsa 99 years ago this month in
the city witnessed the tulsa race
massacre one of the nation's worst
outbreaks of racial violence
recently portrayed in hbo's watchmen
now the reason they're mentioning
watchmen there is a lot of americans
learned about the tulsa race massacre
for the very first time
nearly a century after it happened from
watching that show
basically the night that episode airs
many white americans went
holy i had no idea this happened
while many black americans went
holy white people are gonna freak
the out when they find out this
happened
debbie at work is going to want to have
a conversation the coverage of that
trump rally didn't just introduce many
americans to that massacre but also
to the very concept of juneteenth the
day that commemorates when union troops
informed texas that enslaved people
there must finally be freed
two years after the emancipation
proclamation by the way
a recent poll showed that a shocking 48
of americans were either
not at all or not very aware of
juneteenth which is not
good i mean it'd be fine if nearly half
of americans were unaware of groundhog
day the
meaningless date when an idiot dressed
like goth willy wonka
holds up a non-clairvoyant woodchuck
whose face somehow screams i have better
things to do
but juneteenth actually mean something
and that's just one of
many gaps in knowledge that some are now
realizing that they have just watched
joy behar
try to explain why statues of george
washington should be left alone and in
doing so
actually learning something the george
washington besides being a founding
father and a great general and somebody
who was so instrumental in this
union that we have in this republic also
freed his slaves so if you're going to
take somebody down take down thomas
jefferson who didn't who didn't free his
slaves
no sonny disagrees he didn't
free his slaves he actually spent the
last year of his life
like relentlessly pursuing slaves that
tried to
um run away he was a horrible slave
owner
yeah he was as usual sonny hostin is
very right and megan mccain is very
there
because while washington did promise to
free his slaves in his will it specified
they wouldn't gain their freedom until
his wife's death so
only one person was freed immediately
after washington died out of over a
hundred
also he actually became a slave owner at
just 11 years old a fact so horrifying
it's kind of hard to know what to do
with it at the very least the story of
him
chopping down a cherry tree as a child
and admitting it to his father by saying
i cannot tell a lie gets way less
charming if the next part is his parents
saying
thank you for being honest george as a
reward here are some human beings to own
and the thing is joy behar's version of
history while distorted
is definitely more palatable especially
for white people and seeking out
misleadingly comforting versions of
history is a pattern that we've seen
again and again this year from the
number one movie on netflix during the
protest following george floyd's murder
being
the help to just last week when senator
tom cotton said
schools should lose federal funding if
they teach a curriculum based on the new
york times's
1619 project which brings slavery into
the forefront of american history and
perhaps
the most absurd disconnect was in the
wake of president obama's eulogy for
john lewis this week in which
obama advocated for abolishing the
filibuster if necessary
to expand voting rights tucker carlson
had this to say
imagine if some greasy politician showed
up at your loved one's funeral
and started throwing around stupid
partisan talking points about
senate procedure can you imagine that
you would be shocked if that happened
you'd probably walk out
desecrating a funeral with campaign
slogans what kind of person would do
that
wait what kind of person would honor a
friend's legacy by continuing to
advocate for voting rights you know what
i can think of one john lewis
would do that
and the truth is with so many people
misunderstanding our history either by
accident or
very much on purpose we thought tonight
it might be a good idea to talk about
how the history of race in america
is currently taught in schools what some
of the gaps are why they're there
and how we can fill them and let's start
with the fact that there are no
national standards for what topics or
figures students must learn about at
school and state standards
vary widely when cbs looked into it this
year it found seven states
do not directly mention slavery in their
state standards only two
mention white supremacy while 16 list
states rights
as a cause of the civil war and we
actually did a whole 21 minute piece
about what is wrong with that argument
but this clip explains it significantly
quicker
the root cause of the civil war is clear
what caused the civil war was
slavery the main cause and why the south
decides to succeed was for slavery
so why do our history textbooks get it
so wrong
y'all don't want to deal with the
up that y'all ancestors did
yeah i mean that pretty much sums it up
and it can be hard to deal with what
your ancestors did
trust me i'm british one of our most
famous tourist attractions is a castle
where we executed people for centuries
and are now filled with stolen jewels
like the cohen or diamond which
according to the tower's website
was presented to queen victoria and that
verb
is doing a lot of heavy lifting there it
was presented
in pretty much the same way that india
was in so much as it was present
and britain took it and for all
the current handwringing about how any
changes would
politicize u.s history it's worth
remembering that the teaching of it has
always
been political after the civil war the
battle over how history would be told
in textbooks was intense because you
know the same history is written by the
winners
the south set out to prove that wrong
one organization called the united
daughters of the confederacy
campaigned for schools to adopt
textbooks that would accord
full justice to the south telling
librarians to write
unjust to the south on the ones that
didn't which is clearly absurd
it'd be like a librarian writing unjust
to voldemort
on harry potter's one through seven or
unjust to whale on moby dick or
unjust to l ron hubbard on leah remini's
troublemaker colon
surviving hollywood and scientology but
that impulse
to downplay the horrors of slavery has
marked how school children have learned
about it
ever since a georgia textbook from the
50s claimed
the master often had a barbecue or a
picnic for his slaves
then they had a great frolic and look
every excuse for slavery is shitty
but we gave them sandwiches sometimes
has to be one of the shittiest
and some who learned history from books
like those couldn't believe what they
were being told
at the time just watch this alabama
school teacher revisit her fourth grade
textbook
no alabama some slaves were good workers
and very
obedient many took pride in what they
did
and loved their cabins and the
plantation
as if they actually owned them others
were lazy
disobedient and sometimes vicious
i wonder what kind of slave i would have
been i wonder if i would have been one
of those lazy slaves who just were not
willing to work
for nothing are disobedient because i
just didn't want to be a slave
yeah that contempt is fully merited
there
because among other things the idea that
being a lazy slave was a character flaw
as opposed to
a frequent act of protest against a
brutally unjust system
is infuriating and it makes no alabama
sound
less like the title of that textbook and
more like something you'd yell at
it no alabama stop that bad textbook
no and those passages were in the
standard alabama history textbook into
the 70s
so people who read them and may have
been shaped by their content
and now in their 50s doing things like
running businesses or i don't know
holding elected office and while newer
textbooks
may not be quite that egregious there
are still problems
earlier this year one historian flagged
a pretty remarkable euphemism
in a current texas school book this is a
picture
and the caption says some u.s settlers
brought slaves
to texas to help work the fields and do
chores
and you know i don't think we should
describe
slave labor as tours yeah you're right
we probably
shouldn't calling slave labor chores is
a euphemism on par with calling hitler a
best-selling author with a side hustle
or
jfk's assassination a bad hair day or
this a comedy show
and look state standards and textbooks
are just a baseline here
what happens in a classroom largely
depends on teachers who have a very
difficult job often working with scant
resources meaning that among other
things
they may not be able to get updated
versions of textbooks and some
work really hard to correct poor
materials but others
can actually make things even worse with
tone-deaf assignments
and classroom exercises that you may be
familiar with from seeing local news
stories like these
this is the activity in question it asks
students to choose to be a slave or a
slave owner
and then to write a journal entry that
describes daily activities before the
civil war
the question about slavery read you own
a plantation or farm
and therefore need more workers set your
price
for a slave these could be worth a lot
this north carolina grandmother couldn't
believe the assignment given to her
fourth grader
and in this game it's called escaping
slavery
a slavery themed monopoly like game
students played in elementary school
children worked in small groups got this
freedom punch card
if the group ran into trouble the card
said they'd be severely punished
and sent back to the plantation to work
as a slave
where they going to hang them they're
going to kill them what the are you
doing there
you can't reduce a person's freedom from
slavery down to what is basically a
jimmy john's punch card
and just imagine what it would feel like
to be a black kid in that classroom or
if you don't have to imagine remember
because
it's not just the history that hurts
here it's how you're being made to feel
while you learn it
and the frequency with which stories
like those tend to crop up may have
something to do with the fact that the
overwhelming majority of school teachers
are white and many
may have grown up learning the same
skewed version of history that they are
now
passing on and when you take all of this
together we're giving kids
incomplete educations in history while
also doing real harm
because those kids grow up just listen
to this guy from tulsa explaining how he
felt when he finally found out
about that 1921 massacre that happened
where he
lived when i went to ou in 1998
i was sitting in a class of
african-american history and the
professor was talking about this place
where black people had businesses and
had money
and had doctors and lawyers and he said
was in tulsa and i
i raised my hand i said no i'm from
tulsa
not accurate and he was talking about
this
massacre riots man what are you talking
about i said i went to school on
greenwood i've never heard of this
ever that's terrible and his school
really let him down there think of the
emotional whiplash
that man must have gone through he found
out something amazing at once existed
right where he lived something horrible
had taken it away and
that the history had been kept from him
and all of this had happened less than a
hundred years ago
the dinosaurs died 65 million years ago
and you would still be absolutely flawed
if someone only just told you about them
i'm sorry
there were what where what do you mean
everywhere and they were how big
some of them could fly what happened to
them oh no
how the is this the first time
someone's mentioning this to me
look it is pretty clear that we need to
upgrade the way that we teach our
history and while i obviously
don't have time to go through all of
that history right now it might be worth
going slowly through
three big mistakes that many historians
believe that we make and should correct
in schools and beyond the first is that
we don't fully acknowledge the history
of white supremacy in america from its
founding
to the present day and i know that
anytime someone suggests telling
children anything less than
jesus would have been best friends with
abraham lincoln the pushback is
fierce watch laura ingram take one
school board's discussion of an
anti-racist curriculum
and spin it out into a dystopian vision
designed to terrify
her viewers now every subject every
extracurricular activity
will be perverted to turn your kids into
mini elon omars
they're going to learn that capitalism
is racist history as
conventionally taught is racist
literature most of that's racist
patriotic songs racist and the
declaration and the constitution
of course they're racist are you sensing
a theme here
now laura ingram might not seem like
someone capable of following anything
apart from black teenagers simply trying
to shop at cvs but
i think she actually has picked up on a
theme there because seeing as she
brought up the constitution
let's talk about it because that
document is a lot of things genuinely
revolutionary and the foundation of an
improbably long-lived democracy but it's
also
infused with and inextricably linked to
slavery and a legacy of racial
inequality from the
three-fifths clause through the fugitive
slave clause the constitution both
codified slavery and
made it harder for individuals to escape
it and the fact the constitution is
infused with racism does not mean it's
cancelled
it's not a youtuber who's just now
realizing it was wrong to do blackface
for 14 years
and it definitely doesn't mean the kids
shouldn't learn about it but they should
be taught to see it
as an imperfect document with imperfect
authors who both extolled the ideals of
freedom for all
while at the same time codifying slavery
and
that is possible to do kids can
understand that things can be racist
and also other things the constitution
can be revolutionary and also racist
movies can be romantic and also racist
children's books can be charming
and also racist broadcasters can be
incredibly successful
and also racist and if kids are taught
an incomplete history they'll either
never get the full story or when they do
they don't have the framework to
understand
how the pieces fit together here is one
professor explaining how hard it can be
for his students
learning the whole truth about thomas
jefferson what that child is then going
to do
is say wait a minute why didn't i know
this before
i've been running around here singing
thomas jefferson's praises
and i didn't realize that he's an r
kelly of his time
so while it may be uncomfortable he says
you have to be honest
i i swear ohioans suffer from
underground railroad itis right you ask
him yeah who would have been
who'd have been for the underground
railroad right in class every every
white hand goes i'm like look
if all of y'all would have been down for
the underground railroad
wouldn't have been underground right
there would have been no need for it
okay
first of all it says a lot about
jefferson that if you went back in time
explain to him who r kelly was and told
him he was being compared to him
the child's pornography charges would
not be the number one reason that he'd
be insulted by the comparison
but that professor makes a really good
point there
the less you know about history the
easier that it is
to imagine you'd always be on the right
side of it because the truth is
the history of america is a history of
changing an america
that badly does not want to be changed
and that actually brings us to the
second common mistake that we make
viewing american history's progress as
if it was constantly
and inevitably upward too often u.s
history was reduced down to there was
slavery
then there was a civil war then there
wasn't slavery anymore then there was a
civil rights movement then there wasn't
racism anymore just a smooth
steady upward arc but the moment on
either side of those landmark eras
complicate the hell out of that arc
because they were filled with white
hostility
and ugly backsliding take the century
between the end of the civil war
and the civil rights act which is often
glossed over but should probably be
taught a lot more thoroughly it begins
with reconstruction a dozen or so years
of real promise when very basically
the south was forced to redraw their
constitutions and permit the
registration of black voters that's
right
black men in the south were voting in
the 1860s and 70s
when they fought for the voting rights
act in the 1960s they were fighting to
get back something
that they'd already had the effects of
reconstruction were almost immediate
with an estimated 2
000 black men serving in elected office
during that era including
a number in congress and just look at
these guys
a plus achievement a plus plus facial
hair there and sure
you might think you can grow your
mustache into your beard try it
you can't but in response to
that progress
white people pushed back and pushed back
hard
the kkk was founded 2 000 black people
were lynched and by 1877
the south had regained local control
here is a crazy story that you might not
know
in 1898 the multi-racial city government
in wilmington north carolina
became the target of the only coup
d'etat ever to take place on american
soil in which a mob
of up to 2 000 armed white men killed at
least 60 black residents
and replaced the city's aldermen with
white supremacists
and if this is the first time that you
are learning about the
only coup on american soil you're not
alone
because what happened there is usually
either not taught at all
or as the author of a book on that
massacre points out talk very
very misleadingly here's from a 1949
textbook quote
a number of blacks were jailed for
starting a riot and a new white
administration took over wilmington's
government
end quote yeah that's it and that is not
just denying what happened it's even
worse
it's placing the blame for it on the
victims technically you shouldn't even
call it a history book so much as
a book of lies because we kind of felt a
bit weird about that whole violent
racist coup
thing and wilmington wasn't even the
midpoint of that century of backsliding
and the laura ingrams of the world will
probably say
yeah that's all ugly but in a sign of
american exceptionalism
the civil rights movement ended all of
that when martin luther king's dream
came true and that is the version that
most americans are taught in school but
it leaves
a lot out in fact take the march on
washington that wasn't actually its full
name it was called
the march on washington for jobs and
freedom and the economic justice part of
it was front and center
king actually grew more outspoken about
that issue in the years that followed
and king himself understood why it was
harder to make progress on that front it
didn't cost the nation one
penny to integrate lunch counts
well it didn't cost the nation
one penny to guarantee the right to vote
[Music]
but now we are dealing with issues that
cannot be solved
without the nation spending billions of
dollars
and undergoing a radical redistribution
of economic power
yeah it turns out that martin luther
king had more than one dream
and one of them was about wealth
redistribution so
while i know it's easy to distort king's
full legacy down to that one
soaring speech point to the cast of this
is us and say see
we did it everyone everything is fixed
now
the truth is the civil rights movement
was longer messier
more radical and crucially was thwarted
in more of its aims than many of us were
taught in school
and that actually brings us to the final
point here which is that we don't
connect the dots to the present and
those dots are very much there
look at the black white wage and wealth
gaps they are both larger now
than they were when king gave that
speech and our housing and education
systems
even in liberal cities like new york and
la are still
shamefully segregated and if you don't
teach history properly
all you see is those effects and not the
causes
when the truth is you can draw a
straight line from the post-civil war
return of plantation land to former
confederates
through the massive transfers of land by
the homestead act
mostly to white individuals through the
growth of the suburbs in the 20th
century where
redlining kept black people from moving
into white neighborhoods
throughout the country in fact just
listen to this woman in levertown
pennsylvania
explained her objections to a black
family moving to town in 1957
with some real honesty we like the
advantages that levittown seemed to
offer in
comparison to other cities and we
understood that it was going to be
all white we are very happy to buy a
home here do you think a negro family
moving here will affect the community as
a whole
definitely the whole trouble with this
integration business is
that in the end it probably will end up
with
with mixing socially and you will have
well i think their aim is mixed
marriages and
becoming equal with the whites wow
it is always weird to hear someone
whether or not they look like summer
casual betty crocker
frame human beings being treated equally
as a negative
it's like hearing someone say the whole
trouble with putting graham crackers
chocolate bars and marshmallows together
is that
we might end up with s'mores yeah
exactly
that's a good thing only a
monster wouldn't want that
and it might not surprise you to see
that someone was incredibly racist in
the 1950s but
one of the problems with the way that we
teach history is that too often it sort
of
trails off after the civil rights
movement and when you skip
over the past half century you don't get
to see the process by which white
supremacy instead of disappearing
merely adapted and perhaps nobody made
that process clearer than lee
atwater a top republican campaign
strategist who worked for among others
ronald reagan and george h.w bush here
he is
spelling out the whole game in 1981 and
i'm going to warn you
you're about to hear the n-word a lot
you start out in 1954 by saying
by 1968 you can't say that hurts
your back fire so you say stuff
like force busting states rights and all
that stuff
and you're getting so abstract now
you're talking about
cutting taxes and all of these things
you're talking about are totally
economic things and the byproduct
problem
is blacks get hurt worse than white we
want to cut this and we want
as much more abstract than even the
busing thing
[Music]
and a hell of a lot more abstract than
never never
holy now obviously
he's a little too comfortable with that
word you tend to only hear it come out
that smoothly in either tarantino movies
or online forums in which white children
play video games together
but that is actually a pretty concise
history of a certain thread in politics
for the past half century which brings
us
all the way up to the present day
literally
the present wednesday which is when the
president of the united states
in announcing a rollback of an obama era
rule under the fair housing act sent a
tweet in which
he informed all of the people living
their suburban lifestyle dream
that they will no longer be bothered or
financially hurt by having low-income
housing
built in their neighborhoods and that is
basically a campaign promise
crafted by lee atwater and designed to
win over this woman who's probably dead
by now
and what's notable there is not that
trump's being racist which is not
remotely surprising
it's how neatly he fits in to a systemic
racism
that's been baked into this country from
the beginning and which will still be
here
when he is gone and if kids aren't
taught this
what chance do they have to understand
what's happening right now
and obviously you'd need to calibrate
this to each age group no one is
suggesting
playing that lee atwater take two third
graders but it's a bit like sex
ed you don't skip straight ahead to
ejaculation
which by the way is a pretty good sex
tip for anyone with a penis but we also
don't spend the first semester of sex ed
teaching kids that were all dropped out
of the sky by
stalks because they'll later
have to
unlearn that and i know that addressing
mistakes like these
will not be easy there'll be bad faith
charges that doing so
is political although i would argue no
more political than the choices we've
made to teach history the way that we do
now and
no doubt some parents will instinctively
resist this
back in 2010 when texas was reviewing
its state standards
one parent made it very clear that the
main history he wanted his kids taught
was that of american exceptionalism the
one thing i want my kids to know
when when they get out of school about
america
is that the worst day in america beats
the best day in any other country
it seems like there becomes this great
focus on the negative
history of america instead of saying uh
oh take for instance slavery
instead of you know looking at it in a
positive life that americans
overcame something as evil as slavery
and that we're still a great nation
today should be a testament to the kind
of american spirit
that exists in this country okay so
there's a lot to unpack there first
your worst day in america really depends
on who you are and importantly
when you are there is a reason for
instance marty mcfly was white because
black people generally don't hang around
with john c calhoun lookalikes who are
obsessed with going back to the 1950s
and second americans did not overcome
slavery
certain americans overcame certain other
americans
and slavery was ended but whether it was
overcome
is very much another matter and look
while i understand
any parent wanting their kids to be
taught something inspiring what he's
essentially asking for there
is for his kids to be misinformed and
that's not going to serve them well when
they grow up it's not going to serve
any of us well because ignoring the
history that you don't like
is not a victimless act and a history of
america that ignores white supremacy
is a white supremacist history of
america which matters
because while it might seem obvious
history isn't over yet
it's still being written and you know
who understood that john lewis
he's someone who's very much part of
american history and he knew the
importance of drawing a line from the
past
through the present that might be why
one of the last things that he did
before he died was visit
black lives matter plaza in washington
he even wrote an op-ed
to be published posthumously which
speaks directly to what we've been
talking about tonight
just listen to this extract read by
morgan freeman you must also study and
learn the lessons of history because
humanity has been involved in this
soul-wrenching
existential struggle for a very long
time
people on every continent have stood in
your shoes
through decades and centuries before you
the truth does not change and that is
why the answers worked out long ago
can help you find solutions to the
challenges
of our time exactly history when taught
well
shows us how to improve the world but
history when taught poorly
falsely claims there is nothing to
improve so we have to teach it better
and continue to learn it because it's
important for all of us
to listen to the voices of history
whether they are a call to action
truly horrific or a sad mummy orgasm
still excellent that's our show thank
you so much for watching we're off next
week back august 16th good night